[Music]
Hey, what do
you think?  No, it's not a
good writing machine It's definitely not the husband who is
noisy What are you saying
?  We're the only ones
here, hahaha, you can't fall in love with a woman who doesn't have
a place.
That's a good thing Then why don't you avoid it for a while?
You're asking me my name Some kind of train is coming I'm shouting at the weapon It's drowned out by the sound of the train
Sector
Okay, if they bloomed together, it would really be different.
It was a mischievous prank to make me scream and ask about the person I like
.
Hey, I shouted out my name
[music] I
'm sorry I liked worrying about you As a friend Yes Yes
Sexually yes  Senpai,
if you're going to live, why don't you
choose me?  Every day from now on, I'm going to feel a little eerie and weak, is
n't that also a form of a living master
?  music]